step on kendrick nunn but  forgot the balls he had the great move  here's lebron  [Music]  foul and flip it in it's going to be so  tough to get him square where you fall  straight back and he runs you straight  over he's trying to avoid him there and  that's good enough for the official yeah  you're not set you're still moving  you're still going backwards  i think you're just better  there he is the scariest sight  [Applause]  [Applause]  this one for the highlight reel given  how great a three-point shooter he is  it's it's never mentioned we get to see  it all the time so tough to garden  from everywhere  if he's there  75 games or something the lakers will be  amazing  dropping in the jumper baseboard knows  about that  he's like yeah i know you but i'm still  going straight through your chest look  at how good westbrook is and that's your  point guard  working inside bully ball  ron james  on the kick out west brook that's a  better pass there's the lakers